quartiers généraux dont 1/3 de droite je
me suis entendre on met de côté
vous avez là quatre bassines 4 et plus
et 50 kg de patates on le fait on des
pommes de terre je vous ai convoqué pour
les peluches et les pommes de terre
parce que la machine est en panne
comment il n'ya pas d'ouvriers pour le
faire question pourquoi je vous ai
convoqué toi eh bien je pense que pour
que mes amis de neuilly et moi même nous
libérions c'est féculents de leur
enveloppe charnelle bombardements va
éplucher les patates quoi violent
j'avais compris aller au travail
l'extension et que ça saute donc d'être
ça te dérange pas non je rejoigne micro
pas merci il ya bien comment s'y
prend-on tu prends un patate dans une
main les plus réputés plus enfin
j'aurais préféré plus chez de douce
lorsque je pense qu'ici est plus simple
espace et de prendre le féculent de
vendre une extrémité et avec le couteau
d'abord c'est un mouvement rotatif afin
d'obtenir une seule solution gagner un
temps considérable ce sera un bien
jetable bien laquelle branges
la moins salée si ma mère savait que
travaillant au noir
j'ai entendu une phrase lesquels des
vous il a dit
bilan cinq jours
tu es là tu as une tête qui respire le
masochisme m'expliquer comment on
épluche les pattes intitula j'allais
vite à peine de moitié si tu es plus
élevé que les autres aller parce que
c'est toi c'est dur je me lavais pour le
diabète et moi je sens tu sais l'armée
avant tout c'est la justice oui ces
fumiers communaux et van persie touché
leur ego des taux et par vaux chanter
vous avez déjà tiré oui avec
marie-chantal je parle de char à oui on
va l'année dernière de son parti en
safari avec papa tels que vous me voyez
j'ai chassé l'éléphant bien moi je n'ai
passé que le ferait sens
et bien moi dernièrement figurez vous
que j'ai chassé la bonne ben moi j'ai
tiré la chasse
pardon monsieur excusez-moi sergent
puis-je vous poser une question à dix
pages vous ne seriez manasyan pourquoi
territoire parce que je suis alsacienne
du lot je sais pas qui tu es mais je te
soupçonne doigts oui je suis de
strasbourg j'aurais plutôt cru que les
la forêt noire et 14 jours il boude
vous devez également l'as rome ne s'est
pas tu t'en quelles facs fois demain
j'étais à sciences po tout ça pour finir
sur ce coup de tête appartement minable
et ben moi j'ai raté les mamans étaient
folles et patata et toi tu étais de tuer
de quelle région
je suis 100 de la france vous aimez
d'accord mais de quelles facs
c'est dans le centre de la france de
quelles facs je mets en avant je vous
pas plus quand tu vas pas te fâcher pour
serge ans parce qu'il ya le conte c'est
vrai
dillon et puis en tant que j'ai vu sa
voiture oui il a une simca 1000 avec la
queue du tigre qui prend la main et
pourquoi vous dites que le sergent est
un conte faut dire ce qui est c'est pas
une lumière je trouve un peu mais c'est
pas de sa foi question d'ethnie rue
attendu tant fera quoi alors toute façon
il est pas con c'est un triple adacore
vous et vous tabac bio vous côtoyez des
dangers allez on a produit du jeu et ben
vous voyez les gars est passé des
graisses que ça le macaque
tu côtoies de l'ag
n napoléon est né à bethléem en gagnant
est la pollution du s'amuser à nice on
est tristes engagement napoléon est né
dans une haie natoire la culture c'est
l'accord je pense mais bon il est né un
15 août en plein embouteillage
comme ils sont beaux à suivre tout le
monde est belliqueux doucement à gober
dit qu'elle soit physique
l'accouchement fut difficile à avaler
en effet il était né avec le chapeau sur
la tête ousmane dominique wils rossary
soit compris
les années passent napoléon monte sur le
continent il assiste aux grands moments
de l'histoire exemple la révolution
française
mais rassure il sans pilote qui dubrava
j'étais le roi de france louis saez et
toi album qui tue mais un sans gêne au
18 heures
la royauté terminée et il va prendre la
france en main c'est moi variane mais
bon dans vingt ans plus tard un jour se
promenant dans les tuileries
il rencontre joséphine et
il est mignon ce petit jeu peut le faire
un billet à vertus je m'appelle doudou
de beauharnais pouvoir y tu as tu vu nos
copines qui s'appelle aussi joséphine
joséphine ton nom joséphine baquet on
n'est pas bien mais les allées repensé
et les rapports du couple se dégradent
écoute doudou écoute petit l'éolien n'a
marqué toujours être à de guerroyer à
droite à gauche on ne voit jamais à la
maison les appelle maintenant les
victoires m'appelle bon bah je veux
marcher si des bananes
les grandes batailles se succèdent
marc ago à austerlitz
le soleil brille à hello il brille aussi
laidlaw le champ libre et et à wagram si
je suis l'apogée de l'empiré
incroyablement way
au cours de ces grandes batailles de
grands maréchaux s'il lui ce maréchal
l'est non c'est un mcdonald's parce
qu'on lui amène makoun c'est parfait et
la série avec eux si vous faites vous et
chaque poche sinon les mecs c'est
panamera turbo soldats je suis content
de vous non entre temps il rencontre
marival et chic à nant et chevalet ce
cas
tu viens chez les lions m'appelle
solidarnosc dans la tasse union d'où
naquit le gland
entre temps la russie l'appel mois la
chasse
ouais je suis conseiller de la russie
alors catherine retraite parfaite
laquelle celle de 60 ans mais non la
retraite de russie
crois tu que nous allons y laisser
beaucoup d'âmes bad est une des races il
passe toute larme à gauche c'est bon
pour les municipales pendant la retraite
un soldat raconte en images et vous
qu'ils disaient
sans blague moi j'aimais les jeunes
mais ce fut waterloo chef chef une fois
ils le sont américaines qui puisse
partout là on a la frite malouines
neigeux fonte de la neige alors napoléon
sur la fin se reconvertit et s'installe
à sainte hélène par ici messieurs dames
c'est clair mais la race des napoléon
n'est pas morte
naples et on ne sort pas grandi de cet
intermède merci d'avoir suivi avec nous
cet apéritif du sourire
bonsoir admis
et si tu m as tu vu mais t'as de beaux
yeux tu sais embrasse-moi allait bien
non j'ai plus envie
ouais tu as tu sais toi à toi tu as tout
ce qu'il faut tu veux et en plus
oui il faut aller en place moi dans la
presse - ouais tu veux ou tu veux pas
qu'ils sont en couple on l'a vu un tas
de bois joli heart is always n'ya même
pas fous pas les jo
alors ma chérie tu me reconnais c'est
une attaque aux notes au chocolat tons
caramel mou quand on joue le sucre est
allé marcher ni bien dans ma case c'est
peut-être belle et ben c'est pas de
démenti mais n'arrivent pas aux yeux tu
sais moi oui d'accord mais pas ici
beau succès chery les cantons devront
sanguin hope is ok c'est bon t'as
d'beaux yeux tu sais rien ne disait pas
vieille
t'as de beaux yeux tu sais embrasse moi
kate lui fait sur wii 2008
est ce que je veux me marier avec toi
c'est toi c'est toi encore le pape avec
maman et papa - et surtout marié bat à
sable à les petites femmes de paris tout
elles mêmes au combat jour bonjour
mademoiselle on vous avez les jolis
pieds comme la cigalière
vous avez deux jolis ballons d'avancé
vous avez la tête ne proposerait aimons
celui-ci du poulet
son pénalty mais vivait et miyamoto mais
tout dépend du noma
bon ok t'as d'beaux yeux tu sais
s'était remis des mois les nanas moi
j'ai pas vraiment terminé sur deux jours
c'est vrai je retire ce que j'ai pour
les filles à faire allez viens george
morris
bonjour issue ambitieux mon jour
messieurs bonjour mes soeurs
e
eh bien nous il sent que trois
les autres sont [ __ ]
michel droit et couché oui piratés tour
fait le guignol ses couverts et
marguerite elle a donné un petit mot
d'excusés il ya lui faute port
dommage qu'elle soit pas la marguerite
c'est un vrai boute en train de te
électrique noël apple notre ami mirepoix
longévité bien qu'animée la petite
sauterie cas suivi les funérailles
seniors car ils sont excités que vous
vers le bel avenir si tu me souviens
elle se tenait aux oreilles messieurs
l'ordre du jour mais qui sait qui devait
et les biscuits faits c'est le jeune
alain deux coups avait il avait promis
des boudoirs de venir marquer le coup
qui doit une bouteille d'eau jamais a
fait voir schickel bien messieurs
l'ordre du jour s'il vous plaît le mois
dernier nous avons inscrire notre
dictionnaire le mot faut calmer
vous nous rappeler la définition mon
cher confrère dit que moi je me sens un
peu faible après 4h faut qu'un
l'escroquerie fort répandue dans la
corporation des limonadiers limonadiers
vaudreuil m elle consiste à vendent à
prix d'or un verre de mousse en faisant
croire que c'est la bière merci mon cher
bien nous avons un débattre aujourd'hui
de l'introduction au dictionnaire me
faut qu un propos qu il y en à dire vous
faire mal
il a cultivé neft aidé boudoir les
fouilles ne parlez pas de ce jeune mâle
appris qu'elle manque de tact
figurez-vous qu'il a envoyé des fleurs à
ma femme comme s'ils savaient pas vous
étiez [ __ ]
et messieurs nous avons assez travaillé
en propose de clore la séance
la nouvelle bonne matin ça me permettra
qui a miné ma préface de mon dernier
ouvrage qui rassemble toutes mes préface
rassurez vous messieurs jeudi prochain
c'est moi qui les ramènerait les petits
gâteaux mal je veux voir mes intentions
à la grève
là où allons nous
bien nino mon invité adrien petit
sourire pendant chez des amis jean
truites mais non non non il ya un petit
restaurant côté du studio un très bon
soir
ce soir on improvise avec des jeunes
comédiens qui sont à la fois auteur
metteur en scène interne et qui auront
plus de spectateurs durant en dix
minutes que molière durant toute cette
mon invité adrian bad boy
pour jean-philippe va tirer un premier
sujet d'une main innocente
nous avons la même peur
jeune comédienne deux films
pornographiques sont rentrés à la
comédie française
y at il quelqu'un et mademoiselle
travail physique de l'emploi partenaires
oui je n'ai pas besoin d'accessoires
non on a changé un peu le sujet
bonjour maintenant à me faire dentier
bonjour monsieur longuet bonjour le crav
entier bonjour monsieur janvier bonjour
les plantes y est on sûr ma section
biennoise avez-vous cela n'aille pas bon
et pourquoi mon mari a passé trois jours
dans le coma
ah bon et il est le bouton
comédie française ne sort pas grandie
c'est vraiment improvisé deux un
mouvement de bonne compagnie kinski
merci d'avoir partagé avec nous cet
apéritif de souris bonsoir à demain
fix bon gommage puis jours je m'excuse
de ne pas pouvoir vous embrasser tous
individuellement mais il ya trop de
monde et toutes façons c'est en être
question de tapis cette sordide histoire
de balai blocage organisé par le colonel
a comme elle va me manquer c'est rugby
militaire
car voyez vous les petits gars vous avez
votre âge j'étais comme vous c'était
voleurs fourbe et son roi j'avais le
choix entre l'armée la police
j'ai préféré l'armée parce que la
retraite est plus vite la et en y
entrant j'ai trouvé une famille un père
le colonel une mère france et la même
temps je sais bien c'est bien times have
dans les chiens mais c'était pour le
pays mais rappelez vous toujours j'ai
été juste et humain les rescapés des
dernières grandes manoeuvres de l'année
dernière s'en souviennent à peine les
victimes enterrées nous sommes saouler
la gueule pendant trois jours la hausse
y ait eu des morts mais quand on sait
pas peur n'est pas là je vous remercie
tous du fond du coeur pour les jeunes en
plaqué or elle va très bien dans la
boucherie
oui car l'armée m'a aussi donné à mettet
on va vous demander un petit service
avant de partir une dernière fois les
petits garde a quand même perdu l'indo
jerry lawler zac retarder la corde mais
on ne partait plus ses premiers si des
membres est tout simplement messieurs de
régler vos montres leroy - le cas
en mal de villes si on essaie quelque
chose des prix de l'eau aujourd'hui jean
roch inca mouvement-là jorion coire on a
des petites nattes comme vos derrière
non non non non vous fait mon brushing
classiques comme d'habitude vous
rigolerez avait fait notre client enfin
à passer le réveillon
voilà moi qu'est ce que j'ai mangé s'est
pas défilée j'étais prête à exploser
faut dire que la dame plus ce point
graphie ses chocolats plus et marron
glacé
tiens encore un arlette non je vous
arrête tout de suite aller 10 heures du
matin alors l'idée même de la nourriture
obama chaque fois je suis comme vous
tenez d'armes présenterez vous
présenterez nord de l'yonne au chablis
abachri qu'après de vomir sur la tête si
j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
qu'est-ce que tu n'aies de bol à
l'oeuvre au noir noir noir super pas ma
cuisine comme ça ça coûte moins cher ici
rigolo comme livre ouais c'est un livre
de marguerite yourcenar à moi je n'ai vu
à la télé avec son mari ainsi qu avec
carmen francis lopez
ah non je crois pas non mais si il a
fait d'elle la grande roue cela jean
romanet mais en plus distingués
écoutez arlette alors là vous êtes
gentille à vous me laissez finiront
chapitre juste ça m'a encore fans en fut
rien
vous avez vu que mireille mathieu s'est
mis des graphiques duffy rayhana qui ont
du bol avec ea mobile quoi la frégière
jr coup de poing diabolise le regardais
pas dallas un ballon c'est justement je
regarde pas dallas howard en moi c'est
ça que j'aurais voulu la tetris
mais ma mère à la tavelure maladie pas
d'abord temps ça pète pas furent mec
c'est pas elle dépasse son coin à
tripoter des cheveux gras dont tu veux
gras fromages
soyez pour des problèmes en ce moment
bhaskar mois le jura je me suis disputé
avec mon jus le résultat la motte de
beurre mou c'est pareil à regarder mais
regardez le toucher roger non non mais
touché je vous dis pas c'est pas grave
tenez regardez sa tablette
oui donnez moi un petit peu de coton
s'il vous plaît merci
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
je peste la radio
le d'amateurs encore des dames au salon
étudiant
alors madame tussauds pardon mais
combien son coin comme d'habitude bien
asseyez vous et vous voudriez des
bottins a pour nom se mobilisent avec
des images merci alors la tête comme ça
s'il vous plaît et puis là si vous êtes
comme you lie les français vont encore
devoir se serrer la ceinture ce mois-ci
de café régime ou non mais une cure
silence un prêt pas de mal si un vomi
silence c'est formidable moi j'aimerais
être voyage me verrai à 6 face à la mer
au bas des falaises sur les galets au
alors vous imaginez la glace et la mer
le fauteuil c'est les rochers on est sur
la plage on écoute la mer qu'on a fermé
je vais vous dire un truc c'est pas
possible au salon non mais c'est vrai
une cliente si on lui parle pas le trac
on me fait la gueule alors c'est moi
beaucoup d'hommes je vous rassure là
dessus je vous en voudrez pas du tout
d'accord mettez vous savez bien comme ça
voilà tourné ma tête je suis fier j'aime
bien oui qu'est ce que vous disiez j'ai
59 ans va se voit pas du tout hélas 18
ans maintenant je lis la chasse à 29 ans
il a 18 ans pouvons-nous être heureux
c'est plus tard que ce sera dur j'aime
bien qu'avec mes crayons pour te raconte
tout sera active
les maris les ondes avec marc yevou oui
non oui on à venir mais non vous n'êtes
pas d'enfant 6 4 avaient ils ont quel
âge 20 ans tous les quatre
oui voilà sa flamme était banal il la
coupe en lançant l'année aux fortes
thermostat 7 il avait encore des vip
lettre
voici ce rare depuis plein les mains
peut voir comme miens aussi gérard de
pipelette
je veux demain truc à quand une cliente
unis comme ça toujours comme digg lui
comme une pipelette
et ben moi tu me suis ma technique
j'allais jouer en laisse pas place et
une je parle tout le temps ces machines
pas comment il s'appelle
or c'est bien cette épouse de l'otan
glay là même qu'ils ont rien de bien
c'est non mais si tu avais pas commandé
alors machine elle s'appelle lady di et
je voudrais bien savoir ce qui m'arrive
à lady di et ben moi je vais voter parce
que débute au attendait de vous faire la
mèche la comédie non mais c'est pas vrai
mais c'est pas vrai n'y avait qu'à salon
coiffure la veille que ce soit le mia si
je tombe dessus
on serait tombés sur la base du yul
brynner hongroise et la tête
fort des chiffres il est ce soir fin de
l'étude depuis quatre semaines
jean claude s'est dit ça va danser bons
restaurants supermarchés patrouille est
à nouveau patrick breafing commence tout
de suite par jean-claude l'ailette
hockey consonnes et voyelles a donc là
c'est à moi c'est chacun j'ai vu une
émission à la télé à partir de ce soir
ça a changé
on était là s elle se voyait les
voyelles voyait les bons sauts un soap
dans max n'est pas le croyait alors
consonne voyelle aux consoles votre
voyelles voyelles il veut et consoles
cela souligne et bien le temps est
dépassé jean claude et bien bravo
max se voyait à oui nous nous as un
passé
ces cd parce que ça veut dire soudoyer
marc écoutez je trouve que votre invité
est oui volontiers je vous présente
jénine des bonjours jénine vous venez de
jeunes et de vierges
cette lettre vous avez des enfants
oui jamais de 1 plus simple de la faute
et vous n'avez pas preuve de si j'ai le
trac mais vous m'avez dit que l'on tient
à la main on y va maintenant c'est le
tour bien sûr des lettres ces régions
toujours de simples non non non en place
chacun son temps à ma famille là ce soir
ça a changé
allons-y conseil cap conseil w concerne
ses consoles et consoles x
consoles et consoles le temps est
dépassé alors jean-claude promet de la
cat est s'inquiète moi je trouvais ça
génial
moi j'avais trouvé jarislowsky ça veut
dire sous voyez en quoi le nez avec les
bleus mais par pur yen alors soudoyer
réaction de celui qui soudoient n'est ce
pas et je permets une référence
historique au 12e siècle sous napoléon 2
et soudoyer le seigneur maintenant
partout et maintenant c'est le tour des
chiffres chaque mort est une sélection
de michelle et she recife
bien sûr c'est le tour de gentils 1re 2e
3e 4e
de première et deuxième voilà 0 0 2 1
tu vas pas me dis pour les ronettes
papilles ben moi je crois le second rang
du monde une seconde vague on le comté
- claude deux mois j'ai trouvé trois oui
alors je vous écoute alors 0 puissance
00 puissance égale 1-1 va bien moi 0 - 0
égale toujours 1 - 0 puissance 010
distance c'est-à-dire un moyen égal 0 de
plus un quart d'heure c'est bien il y
avait plus simple deux plus un égale à 3
batterie pour soudoyer
on avait également sous le jet ou sous
payés à ce propos d'ailleurs laissé
traîner l'être ce soir se termine sur la
victoire d'un candidat es sympathie la
fatigue mais je peux vous dire à la
maison ce serait oui mais vous mêmes
droits aux cadeaux mais les cadeaux la
la c'est pour le faire dans les canons
mais à partir de ce soir c'est chaud
du côté du vieux mesdames et messieurs
chers téléspectateurs bonsoir le voleur
d'apprendre la mort des manuels ripoux
qui fut je vous le rappelle président du
rpt et qui est mort subitement cet après
midi pendant l'inauguration de la fête
du vin à la porte de versailles ce soir
sur le plateau rôle du fus qui fit son
plus proche parent du retour pendant la
guerre et qui voudra nous parler en
quelques mots de ce que fut emmanuel
ripoux et au dessus et je suis très
sereine à faire demain
j'avais dit en quelques mots ce que fut
pour vous aimez rire de sa carrière
politique aaa france saf qui avait coûté
en 36 g/t font populaire propres
emprunts et des terriens mourant 44 il
envoie c'est le général de gaulle sur la
bouche et le regard et attendez il a
vendu tous et anigo était cgt qui a fait
d'eux le rpt et péter sarsgaard
sinon tout ce qui bougeait
mes bien chers frères en ce dixième
dimanche avant la pentecôte est le
quatrième après la pose du linoléum
j'aimerais commencer mon sermon par une
question d'ordre moral et de sens
chrétien
premièrement j'aimerais savoir qui a
déposé une savonnette un gant de
toilette et une serviette sur le rebord
du bénitier
j'attends le coupable à confesse et sa
pensée je les peaux pas embarquer dans
toute l'église on est prié de laisser
les bénitiers dans l'état dans lequel on
aime à les trouver en entends je ne suis
pas contre le fait de rigoler de riz de
s'amuser même notre seigneur était
inférieure je n'en prendrai pour exemple
que lazard les poils hasard et marque
tout le monde était plié surtout la date
avait ramassé à la dame
non rien amusez-vous mais laissez les
choses de culte en paix je ne suis pas
non plus contre le fait qu'on s'amuse et
je nous trouve en vous disant que tous
les vendredis afin de ramener un peu de
monde à notre cinéma paroissial un
vendredi sur deux il y aura un film le
premier de la série s'intitulera tient à
mithra la main mon cousin mais mais là
là là où je m'élève là où je m'élève
c'est quand monsieur son pied monsieur
son biais de la sueur qui tricheront
biais et fils vient me proposer dans un
infâme but publicitaire de remplacer
mais hostile par des rondelles de
saucisson sont bien gardés non non on ne
peut pas abuser le vrai fidèle car tous
les fidèles vous le diront il n'y a pas
de peau autour de l'hostie
venez voir
à condition qu'on les écoute la voiture
a précisé la notion d' attention à 2 3 1
mais non c'est pas net et laisse lorsque
tu perds ça nous raconte pas vaut mieux
parler mais non sans pas vous inquiéter
via son copain qui va arriver parce que
son copain il a été prévenu par garnier
du musée qui est un agent double a fait
du quasi b était l'amant de sa mère et
même que ces personnels ne presque pas
vous le dire parce qu'il met la fin on
sait pas a tout à fait raison il vaut
mieux d'ici un mois si c'est rigoler la
première fois j'avais pas qui c'était le
traduisent à balancer à la marque à la
rockhal quelques james bond qui s'en
sort et valtra de sel à ce qu'elle
appelle moi c'est pour toi donc en
m'intéresse pas de savoir si un blanc de
4 à vivre les macarons à contrer la fin
du film
merci ça ira comme ça juillet
dragueur
une autre version du même sujet
et
excusez moi là j'arrive un petit peu car
vous pourriez me le début des rôles
qu'il vient d'avoir plus de sélections
directeur rien ne rentrait dans l'hôtel
étaient les espions qui le suivent
depuis
merci merci mille fois non c'est pas
grave parce qu'il va rejoindre à une
fuite chez dans un bureau j'en ai vu par
une porte dérobée
mais non mais je vous remercie parce que
j'ai mangé pour tout vous dire il ya un
hélicoptère qui va les attendre au rayo
pour s'échapper arrive et vous êtes bien
les bas blancs
merci puis saint pée des avants vous
croyez si si celui-là en costumes sont
une des perles
ce à quoi vous voyez faire c'est lui qui
va le descendre à la fin si le grand
escalier au jeu peut plaisanter c'est ça
fait trois fois que je le vois c'est
toujours aussi nul droit n'envisage un
abonnement tu vois je suis obligé
d'amortir carrière lui lapin et
nullement qu'on les nuls et du jeu le
héros du film y allant jusqu'à la fin
par contre elle est pas mal profitant et
sur écran géant la scène suivante
qu'est-ce que je te disais montcabrier
ces ballons je pense à la scène suivante
il ya le mektoub une porte on va pas
l'eau de la porte s'ouvre
non puisque est bien c'est qu'on s'y
attend paraître à tient là la scène de
france ah bon je t'arrête tout de suite
on voit rien
c'est vrai ça c'est pas mal de l'anah
après près du gros bout dans la lettre
la petite là moi j'aime bien oui c'est
tant mieux parce que va se lever dans
deux grands déplacements à se farcir le
bon bout d'un héritier le grand court a
battu rennes ait jamais eu pour nom mais
je l'aï et le botswana limon
je regarde où c'est trop tard regarde
plutôt bien tu as fais gaffe ça
t'apprend fois je vous dit si je peux
avoir c'est normal il peut pas vous
entends je plais j'en ai dit moi la rue
là il fait qu'il n'a pas versé les
chercheurs mais j'aurais mieux fait
d'aller voir chantal goya
on peut dire bon elle se tient debout à
ménaka décrire salariés mais a juste
après je crois qu'il va se prendre une
mandale ah non ça je peux te dire j'ai
vu enfin le film et je l'apprends après
l'amendement
alors moi je suis sûr que ça va être là
bas ça je peux te dire que non alors
j'ai vaguement la bande à la barre et
oui question paris on parie en parle peu
du film d'accord c'est parier
j'ai bon jour hélas oui je m'entraîne
pour doubler c'est la fin du film du
brouillard ils étouffent profiler un
militant ghazi et c'est toi qu'ils ont
pris abattons jouera pour alain delon
c'est toujours moi mais a fait lui
remarque tu pourrais jouer le même rôle
que lui
cette pression moi l'autre jour on a été
chez nous un cactus dans la pompe pour
un non
il accuse pour le rasoir je dois tu sais
pas l'autre jour j'ai recommencé
j'ai recommencé 36 ans je me suis envoyé
figuration intelligente il faudra six
caméras production qu'à payer
en juillet le dernier moment je tourne
je fais un rameur dans la galère
à
épicerie bah oui c'est pas une boule qui
roule dans ce cas d'enfoncer le clou
mais ces gens là et moi ça fait la
sixième série toujours rien deux heures
qu'on est là croit pourtant j'avais une
pilote et moi j'avais promis de soutien
et gorges
on en a marre tout en avoir besoin alors
je vois il m'en faut 2 c'est comme la
sécu n'envisage toujours pauvre en débat
c'est pour ça que je suis là au combat
franchement marie avec un mec et la sécu
comédons peau et et sourit il est pour
toi tu l'as dit pas son nom mais vise un
peu ces pannes à la poupe k63 mal
43 le chou et la fois la fois d'avoir
une verrue en plus et puisque nous y
sommes ils ont répété avec les patriotes
avaient préparé marseille accueille en
effet ce cas là tu vas tu sais que ma
mère comme on dit cette boîte bruno
gehrig est passé par guingamp téléphone
ça continue on va partir des notes
to'ata raison aux ou à ce qui se passe
j'ai encore perdu une dent
bonjour monsieur séguin ici pour le film
tarzan lajaunie oui les porteurs et les
indigènes c'est le bureau d'à côté
monsieur c'est pas pour ça c'est celle
agence artistique à mme duke duke duke
yves angoy pour le film de trésor à 10
ans avançait à dubaï et vous messieurs
merci mais je vous dis tout de suite
c'est pas possible
pourquoi mais parce que vous êtes
comment ça je suis n'a pas volé pas dans
l'optique en faudra dans l'atteinte du
personnage n'est ce pas on m'avait dit
un seul homme sage alors je pensais que
je pouvais en parlant de singe et toutes
les photos de cheetah là oui oui oui
c'est celle là qu'on a sélectionné alors
vous voyez il n'y aurait pas assez de
contrastes entre vous et la sellette
parce que vous soyez venus la veille
alors qu'un concert
comedia chat l'internât j'ai fait j'ai
fait est ce que j'ai fait j'ai joué il
ya deux semaines à pointe à pitre les
misérables name is here avec 1 euro vous
teniez mais ce genre major des armées
avait dit nassima dans le rôle de
cosette ogm en votre curriculum qu'est
ce que vous avez fait d'os ag fait la
pub publicité ouais j'ai fait la pub
rangs clubistes donc le un super nom
c'est moi qui a fait chauffer de riz
pour lui que j'ai fait dans paul biya
départ je faisais de la wii d'accord on
fait ça c'est la publicité vous avez
fait du cinéma
oui j'ai fait dans le rouge et noir un
bon avec les geronimo cochise dans le
rôle du oui j'ai compris une rouge j'ai
fait la même pub un jour nouveau coach
dans une pub de formage mais c'était le
cas prise non pas les publicités s'il
vous plaît des sorciers dont on ne peut
à la rigueur vous donner un rôle d'un
type qui tombe d'une falaise et qui se
retrouvent dans une marie des crocodiles
il ya eu un accident vous avez été
déchiqueté j'ai été coupé au montage
non franchement je peux pas vous donner
le rôle de vincent parce que bon il
faudra forcer la plage avec vous faudra
tout changer mais en plus son tour la
nuit et alors du mal pour vous car les
messieurs etc existent mais qui est
florissant quand même à la rigueur enfin
vous savez qui est ce qui est pressentie
dans le rôle de jane do derek monsieur
modéré vous voyez à côté de la mairie
c'était donna summer
j'ai écouté le chaton et moderate même
avec senna tu étais pas africaine
moi je peux faire 15 ans et la fecq
monsieur je me prends d'assaf les cas si
vous n'y a pas de problème enfin de
façon vous êtes trop clair pour le
personnel les cheveux braun est juste le
bronze et voilà elle connaissait déjà la
côte d'azur à saint tropez de bombes
deux jours vous n'êtes pas trop l'écurie
a pas de problème mais ce n'est pas vrai
service allô oui la production williams
don most m elle est production oui
bonjour oui alors pour le rôle de tarzan
vraiment ces essais c'est bon c'est ok
alors c'est plus tard dans la jolie
citant jean labonté 1 alors dans le rôle
de tchita dans jane pour les chiites a
et profita pas d'accord y'a pas de
problème on va s'arranger
au revoir monsieur
faire connaître la musique baroque
combien espère denis
combien de brochets regard doit-il se
faire avant présenter jean et xavière
dentier sabatier noah chaussée non plus
s'enflammer
arrête de paix
combien de mairie marché doit aussi
racheter pour faire croire qu'il ya du
monde
baisser
combien de livres 6 cavaliers
et bien conçu mais avant qu'on la prenne
et nous de mon enfant
mais bon c'est dans l'argent arrête de
les payer une grosse percée
vous
combien de films lellouche va-t-il
tourner avant d'arrêter nous les gonfler
combien de voir des patients c'est alors
qu'on sait tous qu'il ait plaidé
combien de princesse un journal fois
mariée pour continuer à vendre sont pas
plus écoute mon enfant
jean a été payé
combien de filles
doit-on encore violée avant de trouver
sa bien-aimée doit-il veiller à fermer
des cours de mon enfant on sait dans la
bande de gaza
viens de temps big boi
vente et au rire dimas notez qu on n est
pas ton nous envoyer après certes et
ortelli
nous pourrons soient payés nous on
aimerait
voilà intentions en ouvrant ses volets
un matin un homme a la désagréable
surprise de voir que durant la nuit
un campeur a installé sa tente sur sa
pelouse
bonjour monsieur c'est moi vous déranger
mais d'où venez vous je viens du canoë
le 17h45
mais vous savez vous êtes là je suis sur
une île déserte et vous savez à qui ils
appartiennent
ses cocotiers ces bambous l'agent mais
je ne vais pas tarder à le savoir et la
trésorerie qui l'eût cru jouer avec moi
je m'appelle non mais je ne vais pas
tarder à le savoir
vendredi ah non nous sommes mardi des
jolies qu'il est bête
je suis ici pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'on a chassé il n'ya pas
longtemps fait un endroit que je
chérissais
la deuxième c'est que j'ai décidé de
vivre en solitaire quoi
côté messieurs vous êtes sur ma pelouse
c'est à vous cette pelouse ah oui c'est
à moitié dans ses rosiers c'est à vous
oui c'est à moi je trouve qu'ils sont
trop bien monter à bord c'est toute
façon d'occuper j'aurais préféré voulzy
plantier des anémones n'est ce pas
perdre album valable à la pompe
comment vos vêtements de seconde main
complètement ton se dérider alors mettez
des messieurs je vous somme de tout ici
ne peut pas s'est emporté la campagne
alors ne me parlez pas de campagne c'est
loupé la mienne comme ceci
sinon vous ne savez pas qui je suis vous
n'avez pas la télé non si l'on a le
droit des blancs vous avez les trois
chalets attendu
vous n'avez pas les trois sais pas
comment je vais faire samedi
vendredi qu'il est bête non
samedi pour voir dallas dur dur les
boules monsieur votre temps et sur ma
pelouse
comment vous parlez de tentes où on m
m'arriver d'une minute à l'autre
comprenez la situation risque d'être
compromettantes compromettantes
oui non et des mois à monter maintenant
tous ici là tout de suite
bah oui tout de suite les pas
l'intention de dormir sur l'herbe
d'autant que retrait il est plein de
fourmis rouges avons une mitterrand
aidez moi à planter ma tente oui j'ai
perçu moi de mon slam tenait les filles
bougez pas jouer derrière avoue j'ai
entendu marchiez vous avez entendu
marché mais non ce n'est qu'une loi de
coco